hey leute was geht ab und damit herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich
hoffe euch jetzt gut ich bin gerade
draußen irgendwo ich hoffe ihr versteht
mich aufs wetter absolut beschissen aber
wir fahren heute ein bisschen durch die
gegend weil ich möchte bauern automaten
checken das haben super sogar viele von
euch in die kommentare geschrieben und
ja ich wohne ein bisschen ländlich also
hier gibt es denke ich den einen oder
anderen der eine muss da hinten irgendwo
sein dann fahren wir jetzt noch hin ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim video
und ja mal schauen was wir heute alles
so für produkte finden da kann alles
drin sein brötchen milch eier honig
irgendwelche sachen ich will einfach mal
gespannt und ich setze mich schnell ins
auto damit ich nicht krank werde das
wetter heute wirklich die leute es ist
so hart am regnen aber hier guck mal da
ist der automat wo die wünschen stehen
was geht
da und jetzt hier erstmal park das ist
hier einfach rennemann zambrano denken
wahrscheinlich auch was macht der
tütchen mit seinem e 8 hat will er hier
milchtankstelle eier honig käse
kartoffeln kartoffeln kartoffeln auch
nicht muss ich mir ein paar kartoffeln
und milch gibt es auch noch das internet
110 als gefäß
angenommen es kaffee
ich muss
das ist dass da ein udl euro 50
und nicht mein geld wieder
danke
ich meine die wert bern
ich hätte gerne live pr.com ich glaube
einfach alles danke hier sind dafür
schon super glasflaschen
und jetzt kann ich mir nämlich für die
milch noch können
käse gemüse
abrufbar
danke und ab ins auto dieses wetter
hilfe hilfe hilfe
schreien leute wir haben einfach so
schlechtes wetter heute naja ich habe
mir jetzt was gezogen ich habe gehofft
wir haben da auch essen drin das wusste
jetzt nicht ich dachte vielleicht kann
man da auch boote kaufen brötchen was
auch immer das war nicht der fall das
einzige was da noch gab war nudeln und
honig unterhalt diesen käse den ich für
drei euro fünfzig mitgehen lassen ab das
heißt dafür muss ich mir jetzt gleich
irgendwo noch natürlich ein brötchen
besorgen ist aber kein problem das wir
schon hin bekommt und was ich aber super
lustig fand war dieser milch automaten
concealer milch ziehen hierfür habe ich
jetzt 65 cent bezahlt das ist ein halber
liter und dann gab es einen anderen
automaten diese flavours wir haben ja
einmal erdbeer flavour und eiscafé jetzt
ist die frage was packe ich ihm davon da
rein ich will eigentlich für das erdbeer
flavour und das ballern wir hier jetzt
mal vorsichtig rein glaubt das mache ich
besser draußen oder
deckel drauf jetzt ist das da unten drin
und jetzt mit das ist natürlich da hier
rein aber hier gleichen schön
milchshake das ist übrigens jetzt
wirklich mein frühstück also ich habe
nächste frühstück werden jetzt 11 uhr
wenn heute erst um 9 uhr aufgestanden
your life style also das kann man sich
ja auch mal gern hin und wieder sind ja
auch gerade schulferien quasi paar
jahren war ich ja auch noch in der
schule da konnte ich um diese jahreszeit
auch mal ein bisschen länger schlafen
bin ich mal gespannt ob das schmeckt
normalerweise trinke ich nie so pure
milch ich mache mir manchmal milch in
meinen kaffee aber das war es auch
darauf liegt schon mal nicht gut auf
euch leute und auf die bauern hier
wirklich da muss man ja was sagen die
bauern großen respekt die machen oft
auch einen harten job und ich weiß dass
viele ist auch nicht ganz so leicht
haben deswegen schau dort draußen alle
bauern wenn ihr bauern seien schreibt
bei in die kommentare hashtag bauer
könnte vielleicht noch ein bisschen
intensiver seine erdbeergeschmack aber
sonst superleicht man schmeckt auf jeden
fall dass das qualitativ top ist das
frische milch ist die wird
wahrscheinlich erst heute morgen in den
automaten gefüllt wer weiß echt lecker
also muss ich wirklich sagen weil
wirklich super milch dann ist jetzt
natürlich die frage wie fahren wir
weiter freundlich kennen bei mir in der
city auch so ein automaten das zum
metzger automat war schon ewig nicht
mehr da können wir den abend hin fahren
aber eigentlich würde ich noch gerne
einen abchecken wir müssen auch ein
suchen das problem ist der ist echt weit
weg glaube ich vielleicht für die noch
leeren würde ich mich jetzt gleich damit
befassen und jetzt kommt mein auto
entgegen ich glaube der kann hier nicht
lange ja keine ahnung gehört uns auf
jeden fall und ich glaube es wird noch
ein interessantes video das später so
leid ich bin jetzt nach hause gefahren
und wir werden jetzt mal den käse
probieren ich bin mir sicher dass
leckerer käse und ich bereite den mal
schnell zu wie ich am liebsten mache
nehmt euch hier einen teller stellt
dieses gerät darauf das habe ich gestern
abend noch verwendet deswegen ist es ein
bisschen dreckig und jetzt nehmen wir
den und rief immer schön ein apa das ist
natürlich nicht so viel käse was wir
haben aber es war geil und es riecht
schon super und um jetzt die quality von
diesem leisten käse herauszufinden
packen wir den hier einfach schön so ein
bisschen auf toastbrot geil wirklich ich
bin gespannt ziemlich easy aber super
lecker man könnte natürlich noch ein
bisschen mehr drauf machen aber geht ja
hier um den käse und dem automaten gab
es halt leider auch nur käse ich bin mal
gespannt wie schmecken wird so leute
meine käse postings hier aha dann fertig
wir müssen wir jetzt mal schnell
probieren ist natürlich jetzt nichts
besonderes aber man kann den käse
dadurch gut schmecken deswegen probleme
musik gibt sie gut verlaufen sind und
ich mag es romantisch zu sein ich möchte
das für mich jetzt nicht anders als käse
aus dem supermarkt aber trotzdem lecker
der 350 gekostet aber gut kann man schon
drüber wechseln der riecht gut und er
ist natürlich auch von regionalen bauern
deswegen hat er gerne 350 für bezahlt
ich habe auf jeden fall noch weitere
automaten ich muss jetzt erst mal
arbeiten und dann sehen wir uns
vielleicht irgendwann irgendwo bei einem
anderen automaten ach leute ich bin ja
schon jetzt habe ich die äpfel ganz
vergessen normalerweise muss man dir
waschen aber da die vom regionalen
bauern kommen kann man da auch so
reinbeißen ein bisschen dreck reinigt
den magen und es ist trotzdem super
abwehr super
reden vom schönen ab einfach ein guter
apfel also dieser apfel ist mehr als ein
apfel wir haben ja ein apfel ja wirklich
im apfel abgang einfach ein apfel
leute nächste automat alter wirklich ne
kann man hier gibt es sogar kameras
hallo hab mich jetzt seit gestern ein
bisschen bei diesem thema automaten
befasst aber ich niemals gedacht dass es
so viele in direkter nähe zu mir gibt
also hier gibt es echt jetzt noch mehr
als bei dem wo wir morgen waren und der
ist wirklich in meiner stadt und ich
kannte den gar nicht ist natürlich die
frage kartoffeln alter oder kann man
eigentlich preis indymac an bio äpfel
zucker gurken ich kaufe jetzt einfach
mal ein hier kommen metzger gstaad mit
den kartoffeln die 41 sagt sorg und mit
karts acht man kann sogar nur mit karte
zahlen auch mit bargeld natürlich so 25
euro kredit habe ich jetzt dafür brauche
ich gar nicht hier weil müsste auch noch
und was ist das hier fassbrause ein euro
nur hey das ist wirklich top preislich
ne hammer kartoffeln das hätte ich noch
gerne habe ich schon lange nicht mehr
gegessen das sind auch natürlich nur
gute ein
wildschwein leberwurst hh geflügel
currywurst haltet ihr haben wir wirklich
viel nach oben sind auch orangen
deutsche zwiebeln und hier sind jetzt
meine eier
dankeschön und wenn wir jetzt schon mal
hier sind dann nehme ich mir noch die
bio äpfel da unten mit leute hier schon
mal da ist die 52 können wir ein paar
äpfel hier dann reicht's aber auch nicht
mehr brauche ich eigentlich nicht
vorsichtig bitte
nein jetzt habe ich das kaputt nein es
ist kaputtgegangen super sack äpfel
birnen
aok und bkk
abfahrt nach hause noch meine kartoffeln
ehrlich so leute da können wir den
automaten noch mal sehen wirklich ich
muss sagen das haben die wirklich schön
eingerichtet so an nach hause jetzt so
wir haben nämlich bei uns in der city
und jetzt gerade noch lange düst sondern
metzgerei hier kann man nämlich fleisch
kaufen jetzt mal was schönes aus und das
zeige ich euch dann gleich und ich
dachte mir beziehen sollte jetzt wird es
richtig heiß ist ja mehr die kartoffel
in den schreiben städten sowie für immer
und dann war ich noch bei dem metzger
automaten von dem ich euch heute morgen
erzählte wohlhaupter ein stück
fleischwurst nicht mehr viel vielleicht
aber immer wieder ein bisschen und das
richtig mir jetzt an draußen am grill
den heißt schon schön vor und ich glaube
es abendessen leute schaut mal grill ist
anders geworden ist qualmt es übel hier
haben wir ein stück gramm steak ja das
ist auch wirklich gutes fleisch soweit
ich informiert bin wird das bei dem
automat wo ich jetzt als letztes war
auch jeden tag frisch reingepackt ist ja
auch irgendwie logisch und denke ich bei
allen bauern automaten so fasst seien
kein plan oder vielleicht nicht jeden
tag aber die sind ja auch gekühlt und
hat sollte ja schon funktionieren ich
habe dafür ja auch echt viel geld
bezahlt habe ich dann mein grillbesteck
grillzange und letzte was wir ein
bisschen aufpassen christian us schaut
euch das mal an hier werden eigentlich
meine bürger gebrutzelt ihn war dass man
ein stückchen zurück ein bisschen
gewürzt habe ich das ganze let's go
wunderbar und zu die kartoffeln vom
automaten sind auch im ofen und wir
sehen uns gleich wieder wenn das ganze
fertig ist moment da weiß ich gar nicht
mehr ob ich das noch drauf hatte ich
habe noch nie hier schaut mal hier haben
wir so ein selfmade kräuterquark dann
gab es nur 50 cent geil alter das riecht
super kommen ketchup darf ich nicht ich
habe jetzt keinen kitsch aber aus
automaten aber ist okay ketchup muss
aber ganz schön fest hier kummer sieht
aus wie im restaurante einen
wunderschönen guten abend mein automaten
essen ist angerichtet also das hätte ich
heute morgen wirklich nicht gedacht dass
ich heute hier kartoffeln liegen habe
und noch so ein gutes stück steak es ist
wirklich ein gutes stück ich hoffe das
ist mir gelungen ich würde es einmal
hier ein bisschen anschneiden ist würde
ich sagen gut medium geworden kann man
essen und was ich immer ganz wichtig
finde ist wirklich kräuterbutter auf
steak zu machen so richtige keller
machen das ja nicht weil die sagen dann
geht die qualität oder dann schmeckt man
die qualität von fleisch nicht aber ich
würde das gerne machen und damit auf ein
leckeres video
[Musik]
also die kartoffeln finde ich super
vielleicht ist das doch noch ein
bisschen zu
ruhig
ein bisschen genervt hat ich habe die
fassbrause vergessen aber
ich habe ja einiges gekauft heute über
den tag und mich auch wirklich
ausschließlich nur von diesen sachen aus
den automaten ernährt bis auf eine
ausnahme ich habe den käse brötchen
gegessen
und hatte auch nicht so ein richtiges
mittagessen aber das geht klar wenn ich
jetzt dass sie erst jetzt 19 uhr für
alles zusammen habe ich 31 euro
ausgegeben das lag auch daran weil das
stück fleisch relativ teuer war trotzdem
werde ich glaube ich auf diese automaten
weil ich jetzt weiß wo sie stehen öfter
mal zurückgreifen hier könnte mal bei
euch in der umgebung aus checken ob ihr
auch so bauern automaten habt echt cool
ist natürlich eher in den ländlicheren
gegen vertreten heute vielen dank fürs
zuschauen aber hier super ganz den kanal
war kann man vielleicht wären die
millionen und schreibt ihnen weitere
ideen für automaten kommentare ja das
wird mich sehr freuen
[Musik]